I did a little bit of tweeting yesterday, as one does,
and uh I was talking a bit about my, uh,
anxiety and depression.
Which are things that I have.
Now you know that.
It's been a long road for me figuring out, kind of,
what on earth has been going on with my brain.
I've had anxiety I think all my life,
and depression started when I was around 16,
I wanna say.
Which, coincidentally is when I started YouTube.
Don't know if those two things are connected but... pretty sure they are.
And for a long time I sort of felt like
those were just things that I was,
like I was just an anxious person,
I was just a bit of a depressed person sometimes.
But I also didn't really feel comfortable kind of, um,
admitting that I had any real problems, you know?
I honestly just thought I was being, you know,
a bit whiney, you know, I thought,
it's not that I'm depressed, I'm just lazy.
It's not that I'm... you know, anxious I'm...
I'm just a bit scared, that's the way I am,
I need to, you know...
man up and- and deal with it.
Part of the reason I was sort of,
nervous to talk about this topic as well is because
there is, a kind of, a certain amount of
bumming out that you're allowed
to do on YouTube it feels like.
It's OK to have problems in videos so long as you can
find a way to say at the end that you, you know,
you're getting through, you know,
you gotta find the upside.
In the first tweet that I posted with anxiety at least,
I don't know, there way a way
I could kinda like make it like a
fun, like, relatable type of thing...
it just feels like the sort of thing you need to do
which shouldn't be the way that it
is but that was my feeling initially.
Whereas with depression...
it's just not fun to go through that at all.
There's no way to share that and be like...
but we're getting through, guys,
and everything's gunna be fine.
You just feel like shit, and...
then you get through eventually, but...
that's not the kind of thing that people
wanna hear a lot of the time, I don't think.
It has only been recently that I've been like,
formally diagnosed with these.
And to be honest the first time
I went to see a doctor about it
I kind of got, like, brushed off.
He was like, eh, this probably isn't a bit deal so...
maybe go and see a therapist if you can but, I dunno.
And that didn't really feel right to me,
so I went to a different doctor and, uh,
she formally diagnosed me
with anxiety and depression.
And I'm on medication for it as well now.
Personally, I don't feel like I could
get by if I was just taking medication.
I also see a therapist.
I also try and do things that
I know will make me feel better.
But it's, you know, it's a case of whatever works for you.
I don't feel like I would ever-
like it's images like this one that you
see and you're just like, well, come on!
Yes, like, sometimes for me going out on a walk
in the nature acts as an anti-depressant, sure!
It doesn't always work like that. But I also need
to take medication to reach a certain baseline.
But that's just me personally... whatever.
The one thing that medication
really did help me realise though
was that it was an illness.
It was a very kind of physical way of being like,
you are taking a pill for an issue that you have.
So it's not a part of you.
And separating those two things,
me from the illness,
was very important for me personally.
When I posted the tweets initially I think the thing that I
thought I was doing was letting other people know...
hey, this is a problem that I have,
so if you have it too we can go through this together.
I thought that I was doing it to
try and like help other people.
But what actually happened was
that I just got a really big outpouring
of support from people on twitter that, um,
I kind of haven't experienced in a while.
And, um, it genuinely made me feel better.
I think part of this is just wanting to really
try and be as honest and authentic as I can.
I still kind of really believe that that's important,
especially kind of on YouTube these
days where I feel like a lot of people
do have this weird kind of
like manufactured authenticity.
Like it's like a phoney version of feeling
like you're connecting with someone.
And I don't like that. I kind of want to rail against that.
Even if it does mean I bum people out,
I just really wanna be like...
this is real. This is who I am.
Anyway, I'm in Toronto. That's what this is.
I'm in an Airbnb right now.
Last time I was here I actually, uh,
had some real problems with my anxiety.
I remember once, I-
all I had to do was go out and get lunch,
and it took me like a good hour of,
like, sitting and like hyperventilating.
What are all of the thing that could possibly
go wrong if I go out and get some lunch?
If I go to a resturant I haven't been to before?
It's like, yeah, rationally it doesn't make any sense.
But, for me at the time, it was, like, genuinely terrifying.
And I was worried about that happening again, but
I have definitely found that I am improving.
I've been out multiple times
while I've been here to get lunch.
Although it has been nerve-racking,
it has not been as bad as it
has been the last time I was here.
That's maybe the positive I can
end this on to make you feel like,
"Eh! Everything's going to be alright!"
I hope it will be, but um, you know we'll- we'll see.
I'm just doing my best.
And, uh, yeah.
If you're going through similar things as well,
I feel ya. I really do.
And yeah, sorry that this was a rambly mess,
but I couldn't really...
this felt like the right way to do it.
Hope you have a great day, uh and
I'll see you in the next one of these,
whenever that might be.
Who know these days, eh?
Thanks for watching. Bye, guys.